♪ ♪
>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
DEMOCRATS, THE MEDIA MOB ARE
FOCUSED ON ONE THING AND ONE
THING ONLY AND THAT WAS THE ONE
RIGHT THAT TOOK PLACE ON JANUAR.
NOT THE 574 RIGHTS OF THE SUMMER
OF 2020.
IT'S LITERALLY ALL THEY HAVE,
THEY ARE CLINGING TO IT AND
ABORTION LIKE MANNA FROM HEAVEN,
THE ONLY POLITICAL ISSUES THEY
THINK THEY HAVE.
HAVE TAKEN EVERY WORD OF THIS
WEEK'S DOUBLE HEARSAY WITNESS AS
COMPLETE GOSPEL TRUTH, THEY HAVE
RACED TO THE FINISH LINE AND
MANY IN THE MEDIA MOB IN
PARTICULAR THEY HAVE ANNOUNCED
THAT FORMER
PRESIDENT DONALD J. TRUMP IS
GUILTY OF EVERYTHING SHE ACCUSED
HIM OF.
NEVER MIND THE MANY REPORTS THAT
TWO SECRET SERVICE AGENTS DENY
THEIR ALLEGATION THAT
DONALD TRUMP A TRY TO COMMANDEER
THE VEHICLE THAT HE WAS BEING
DRIVEN IN.
NEVER MIND ONE OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ATTORNEYS SAYS
GIVE A CHURCH HE TESTIFIED UNDER
OATH THAT WAS HER HANDWRITING,
IT'S MY HANDWRITING.
SHE DID THAT UNDER OATH.
NEVER MIND THAT THE
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S DENIALS THAT
HE WANTED TO WAIVE ARMED PEOPLE
INTO THE RALLY, HE HAS THAT
NIGHT IT.
HOW ABOUT WE DO A FEW SIMPLE
THINGS AND NOT RUSH TO JUDGMENT
AND MAY BE GIVE PEOPLE THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT.
LETS DO THESE THREE THINGS.
LET'S HAVE THE SECRET SERVICE
AGENTS, LET THEM SIGN SWORN
AFFIDAVITS, THEY DON'T HAVE TO
GO BEFORE CAMERAS AND GIVE UP
THEIR CAREERS.
HOW ABOUT WE DO THIS?
WHY DON'T WE HIRE THE BEST
PROFESSIONAL HANDWRITING EXPERTS
BECAUSE I WOULD BET A LOT OF
MONEY THAT THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT IT WAS
TRUMP'S LAWYER OR THE HEARSAY
WITNESS WHO ACTUALLY WROTE THE
NOTES THEY REFERRED TO IN
HEARINGS THIS WEEK.
HOW ABOUT WE SEE IF ANY OF THE
PEOPLE THAT WERE MANNING THE
METAL DETECTORS WERE EVER ASKED
TO STOP DOING THEIR JOBS?
WE CAN PUT THEM BEFORE THE
CAMERAS COME WITHIN THE
COMMITTEE CAN INVESTIGATE
WHETHER THE PRESIDENT AUTHORIZED
THE NATIONAL GUARD AS A FOCAL
PEOPLE WITH THE PRESIDENT ON
JANUARY 4TH HAVE SAID TO US
RIGHT HERE ON THIS PROGRAM, THEY
WITNESSED HIM DOING IT.
THIS IS AN AMAZING DISTRACTION
FOR THE DEMOCRATS AND THEIR
PRESS SECRETARIES IN THE MEDIA
MOB BECAUSE THEIR POLICIES ARE
FAILING ON A SPECTACULAR AND
UNPRECEDENTED LEVEL.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO TALK ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE THEY WILL STICK TO
JANUARY 6TH.
THEIR PRESIDENT, HIS RADICAL
PARTY IS A DISASTER FOR THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY COME AS A RESULT
AMERICA'S ECONOMY IS
HISTORICALLY BAD.
THAT THOU JUST HAD IT'S WORTH
SIX MONTHS TO START A YEAR SINCE
1962.
THE S&P 500 IS UP TO THEIR WORST
START SINCE 1970 AND THE NASDAQ
HAS THEIR WORST START EVER.
BREAKING TODAY THE ATLANTA FED
IS PROJECTING OUR ECONOMY WILL
OFFICIALLY BE IN A RECESSION BY
JULY.
THAT'S DEFINED BY TWO QUARTERS
OF NEGATIVE GROWTH.
A FEW DAYS AGO THE
ADMINISTRATION WAS TELLING US
NOT TO WORRY ABOUT A RECESSION,
THAT IT WAS NOT INEVITABLE.
THESE ARE THE SAME GENIUSES THAT
PROMISED THAT INFLATION WAS
TRANSITORY, THE SAME GENIUSES
WHO SEEM TO BELIEVE THAT SOME
KIND OF MAGICAL TRANSITION TO
WIND AND SOLAR IS UNFOLDING
BEFORE OUR EYES AND WILL BRING
US TO THE RENEWABLE ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE PROMISED LAND
BECAUSE JOE AND HIS RADICAL NEW
GREEN DEAL SOCIALISTS THEY
PROMISED US THAT THEY WOULD
AMERICAN FOSSIL FUELS.
WHEN THEY SAID THEY WOULD
ELIMINATE FOSSIL FUELS, THEY
DIDN'T SAY ONLY DOMESTIC FOSSIL
FUELS.
THEY HAVE NO PROBLEM IMPORTING
RUSSIAN OIL, OPEC NATIONS OIL,
SAUDI ARABIA AND OIL, THEY ARE
OPEN TO IMPORTING OIL FROM
VENEZUELA AND I HEAR THEY TOOK A
MILLION BARRELS OF OIL FROM IRAN
LAST YEAR.
THEY HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THEY ARE
DOING AND THE PAIN IN THE
SUFFERING OF THESE RADICAL
POLICIES AND ALL THAT PAIN THAT
THIS CAUSING EVERY AMERICAN NOW.
EARLIER TODAY WHEN JOE BIDEN WAS
ASKED HOW LONG AMERICANS WOULD
NEED TO FIT THE BILL FOR THESE
RISING GAS PRICES, HE SHRUGGED
IT OFF AND SAID AS LONG AS IT
TAKES, TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE ARE GOING TO SUPPORT
UKRAINE AS LONG AS IT TAKES.
LOOK AT THE IMPACT THAT MORE ON
UKRAINE HAS HAD ON RUSSIA.
THEY HAVE HAD TO RENEGE ON
NATIONAL DEBT FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN ALMOST 100 YEARS.
THEY HAVE LOST 15 YEARS OF THE
GAINS THEY MADE IN TERMS OF
THEIR ECONOMY, THEY ARE IN A
SITUATION WHERE THEY ARE HAVING
TROUBLE BECAUSE OF MY OF --
DEALING WITH WHAT CAN BE
EXPORTED TO RUSSIA IN TERMS OF
TECHNOLOGY.
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TROUBLE
MAINTAINING OIL PRODUCTION
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
TECHNOLOGY TO DO IT AND NEED
AMERICAN TECHNOLOGY.
>> Sean: WHERE IS THE SENSE OF
URGENCY, THE SENSE OF CAPTURING
THE MOMENT AND HELPING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE?
APPARENTLY JOE BIDEN DOESN'T
FEEL YOUR PAIN.
MAYBE HE THINKS EVERYONE FLIES
AROUND THE WORLD COLLECTING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FROM
OLIGARCHS AND BAD ACTORS IN
RUSSIA OR THE BANK OF CHINA OR
OIL AND GAS COMPANIES IN UKRAINE
LIKE HIS SON ZERO EXPERIENCE A
HUNTER VEHICLE MAY MAYBE
JOE BIDEN SIMPLY DOESN'T CARE OR
DOESN'T EVEN KNOW.
THERE IS ONE PERSON AND ONE
PERSON ONLY WHO DECREASED
AMERICA'S DOMESTIC SUPPLY OF OIL
AND GAS -- IT WASN'T
VLADIMIR PUTIN, IT WAS
JOE BIDEN.
JOE BIDEN DOESN'T CARE ABOUT THE
TRUTH, LISTEN TO THE PRESIDENT'S
DERANGED SPEECH IN EUROPE WHEN
HE SOMEHOW MANAGED TO ATTACK THE
U.S. SUPREME COURT ALL WHILE
LYING ONCE AGAIN ABOUT
INFLATION, TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE HAVE THE STRONGEST ECONOMY
IN THE WORLD, ARE INFLATION
RATES ARE LOWER, THE ONE THING
THAT HAS BEEN DESTABILIZING IS
THE OUTRAGEOUS BEHAVIOR OF THE
SUPREME COURT OF THE
UNITED STATES, OVERRULING NOT
ONLY MOVIE WEIGHT BUT
ESSENTIALLY CHALLENGING THE
RIGHTS TO PRIVACY.
WE HAVE BEEN A LEADER IN THE
WORLD IN TERMS OF PERSONAL
RIGHTS AND PRIVACY RIGHTS AND IT
IS A MISTAKE IN MY VIEW FOR THE
SUPREME COURT TO DO WHAT IT DID.
I CAN UNDERSTAND WHY THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE FRUSTRATED
BECAUSE OF WHAT THE
SUPREME COURT DID.
I CAN UNDERSTAND WHY THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE FRUSTRATED
BECAUSE OF INFLATION.
>> Sean: IN TRUTH WE HAVE TO
REMIND YOU HE WASN'T A LEADER IN
CIVIL RIGHTS, HE PARTNERED WITH
A FORMER KLANSMAN NAMED ROBERT
BYRD WHO TRIED TO STOP THE
INTEGRATION OF PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
HE DIDN'T WANT THE SCHOOLS IN
HIS WORDS TO BECOME RACIAL
JUNGLES.
LET'S HELP EDUCATE JOE BIDEN
BECAUSE HE'S DEEPLY CONFUSED AS
EVERYBODY KNOWS.
EVERY SINGLE OTHER COUNTRY HAS A
LOWER INFLATION RATES THAN OUR
COUNTRY, THE USA.
IN FACT ALMOST EVERY CIVIL
COUNTRY IN THE DEVELOPED WORLD
HAS A LOWER RATE INCLUDING
CANADA, GERMANY, FRANCE, ITALY,
JAPAN, SAUDI ARABIA, I CAN KEEP
GOING.
FOR JOE TO ATTACK ONE OF
AMERICA'S GREATEST INSTITUTIONS,
THE U.S. SUPREME COURT WHILE ON
FOREIGN SOIL, IT'S PRETTY LOW
EVEN FOR HIM, DON'T TAKE MY WORD
FOR IT, LISTEN TO JOE BIDEN
HIMSELF BECAUSE HE SAID IT IN
2017, TAKE A LISTEN.
>> WHAT WORRIES ME MOST IN A
NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD HAVE TO
MAKE THIS SPEECH OR WANT TO MAKE
THIS SPEECH -- THE DRUMBEAT OF
DENIGRATION OF THE INSTITUTIONAL
STRUCTURES THAT GOVERN US IS
DANGEROUS.
WHEN YOU DELEGITIMIZE THE
COURTS, YOU DELEGITIMIZE
LEGISLATIVE BODY.
>> Sean: IT DOES RAISE A LOT
OF QUESTIONS, DOES JOE BIDEN
HOLD ANY REAL PRINCIPLES OR
VALUES OTHER THAN ENRICHING
HIMSELF, HIS FAMILY AND GOING TO
DELAWARE EVERY OTHER WEEKEND?
PRETTY MUCH EVERY WEEKEND, THE
COUNTRY IS FALLING APART.
JILL BIDEN IS DODDERING ALONG
DOING WHATEVER HIS FAR LEFT
ADVISORS TELL HIM TO DO AND IT'S
NOW SO BAD EVEN TOP DEMOCRATS
ARE VOICING THEIR CONCERNS.
TONIGHT ACCORDING TO A POLL
CONDUCTED BY THE AP, A VAST
MAJORITY OF DEMOCRATS, 78% THINK
THIS COUNTRY, OUR COUNTRY IS
HEADED IN THE WRONG DIRECTION
UNDER JOE BIDEN -- THAT'S
DEMOCRATS.
IS REAL CLEAR POLITICS AVERAGE
HAS HIS APPROVAL UNDER 38%, THE
LOWEST POINT IN HIS PRESIDENCY.
THAT INCLUDES OUTLIER POLES THAT
GIVE HIM HIGH APPROVAL RATINGS
ARE NOT REAL.
FORMER OBAMA ADVISOR DAVID
AXELROD IS NOW VENTING ABOUT
JOE BIDEN EVEN ON FAKE NEWS CNN,
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHEN THE PRESIDENT GOT INTO
THOSE QUESTIONS, GAS PRICES AND
INFLATION AND ABORTION RIGHTS,
THERE WAS A LOT LESS OF THAT
CERTAINTY, A LOT LESS OF THAT
EMPHATIC NATURE OF HIS INITIAL
PRESENTATION ON NATO BECAUSE HE
DOESN'T HAVE GREAT ANSWERS.
>> Sean: IT'S EMBARRASSING FOR
JOE BIDEN, THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
BUT SO MUCH WORSE FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT ARE
STRUGGLING TO FILL UP THEIR GAS
TANKS AND PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE
BECAUSE WE HAVE A HUMAN
VEGETABLE WHO PROBABLY DOESN'T
KNOW WHAT DAY OF THE WEEK IT IS
TODAY AS PRESIDENT.
HE IS SURROUNDED BY A BUNCH OF
RADICAL BLOKE STAFFERS WHO DON'T
KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THE ECONOMY
OR ENERGY OR ANYTHING ELSE.
IF JOE BIDEN IS NOT MENTALLY OR
PHYSICALLY UP TO THE JOB, HE
SHOULD RETIRE.
A FULL 59% IN A NEW POLL OF
AMERICANS SEE EXACTLY WHAT I'VE
BEEN TELLING YOU SINCE THE
CAMPAIGN.
I WAS THE LONE VOICE OUT THERE
SAYING THIS GUY IS WEAK AND
FRAIL ON A COGNITIVE MASS, IT
WASN'T HARD TO SPOT.
NOT 59% OF AMERICANS SEE IT.
THINK ABOUT THIS, JOE BIDEN
ALMOST NEVER TAKES QUESTIONS
FROM THE PRESS.
THE ONLY SITDOWN TV INTERVIEW IN
THE PAST SIX MONTHS WAS
JIMMY KIMMEL, IT WASN'T A BARN
BURNER.
ACCORDING TO POLITICO, THE
WHITE HOUSE AVOIDS USING THE
OVAL OFFICE FOR PRECEDENCE
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE A
TELEPROMPTER AND LOOK AT YOUR
SCREEN DURING MEETINGS, HE IS
RELYING ON GIANT NOTECARDS LIKE
THAT SAYING "SAY HELLO, THEN SIT
IN YOUR SEAT.
ASK YOURSELF COME OF IT IF HE
CAN'T HAVE A CONVERSATION
WITHOUT A NOTE CARD OR DO A Q
AND DAY WITHOUT A TELEPROMPTER,
ARE YOU REALLY CAPABLE OF BEING
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA?
I WOULD ARGUE THE HARDEST JOB IN
THE WORLD.
IN THE COMING MONTHS AS AMERICA
NOW BATTLES THIS RECESSION,
STAGFLATION AND PROBABLY WORSE
AS WE BATTLE SPIKING GAS PRICES,
ENERGY PRICES, HE SAID T